Hello 大家好 我是阿迪
今天呢 要来跟大家分享一个
我们近期喝到非常非常厉害的手冲手法
说到手冲手法呢
你第一个想到的是谁
曝骨哲
四六法
那前一阵子曝骨哲又分享了另外一个手法
而且他说比四六法还要完美
我觉得是简单的
应该说他的成功率更高
那我们这几天在家冲咖啡的时候
都也是使用这个手法
不管用什么豆子
浅焙 深焙
喝起来都变得很甜
都变得更好喝
而且他不是说有很多选手
就问他说
诶那个传授一下
对
以上一次要通三杯
那如果这个手法又稳定
然后又好喝的话
那就是非常适合比赛
做地手法
对
那今天呢要来跟大家分享
这个呢
其实我也不知道叫什么名字
他是说来自上帝的食谱
我们要准备的东西呢
有这个
有开关的滤杯
曝谷则他使用的就是Hario Switch
这个可以做浸泡
也可以做地律的这样的一个滤杯
那這次呢也非常感謝台灣Hario
提供我們這個綠杯來使用
再來呢
要準備一個冷水壺
等一下這個手法會使用到降溫
那我們先分享一下這個手法
然後等一下再來跟大家說明一下
為什麼這個手法會讓咖啡變得更好喝
豆子要20克
20克
這次都已經在倒進去了
每次都沒說
這個研磨度呢
可以依照個人喜好
你想要它濃一點就可以磨細一點點
然後如果想要它淡一點點的話
那就可以磨粗一點
那我們今天用的是Easy Pressel 的K
然後我們是用顆度5.8
就跟平常一樣
對
那我們今天會用92度
其實也就是我們平時使用的習慣的那個溫度
好
20顆的粉下去等一下呢會分三段注水第一段注水注60克第二段注水也注60克
前面兩段要把開關打開
就讓它呈現一個低率的萃取
最後一段注到280克
要變成浸泡
第一注水我們注60克
開關打開
撲骨則是說
隨意繞圈就好
粉都有吃到水醬就可以了
其實我發現很多
就是像我之前去布達佩斯或新加坡
看很多咖啡師他們在悶整的時候
注水速度都很快
而且注的量也很多
我覺得也蠻合理的
就是讓所有粉是在幾度同時的時間吃到水分
不然如果注了30秒還有粉絲乾的
那它就會比別人少30秒時間的水分
然後30秒的時候我們要注到120秒
然後這時候中間我們就來讓水溫降溫至少要降到70度
然後等到它流的差不多的時候
就可以把開關關起來
然後它就會變成浸泡
1分15秒的時候我們要鑄到280
1分15秒鑄到280
好,這樣子
所以這樣就完成了
然後這個浸泡呢,浸泡到1分45秒
就可以把它濾下來
那破爐的是有說啦,就是整段的萃取時間不要超過三分鐘
就是說如果你三分鐘到了,你看它水還沒有全部流下去
就可以直接先把濾杯離開
那之後如果覺得太濃
你再去加水就好了
所以不要萃取超過三分鐘
應該就避免一些後段的一些苦味啊
色味跑出來好,我們等一下就來喝看看那像我們這次呢大概2分50秒左右其實差不多 差不多 對
好 那全部留完了
OK
那我們就喝看看啦
超甜 超好喝
而且我们已经用了比较酸的豆漬
对对
因为我们之前有去配配方
然后有放肯亚
然后那时候一加肯亚就说
啊 它变好酸啊
就是肯亚还是有一个比较刺激的酸
但这个做法呢
就可以让酸味没有那么突出
它不会那么刺激
然后但是我觉得它后段的甜感就很扎实
我觉得它是很顺
就是不会有那种尖锐的
对对对
有些咖啡会有个色色吗
或者是尖锐
然后body不好的那个感觉
对这个做法它的body会非常好
后段因为用浸泡的关系
所以就会让它整个后面的味道
就变得很温和很饱满
这个手法我们也有试过
用比较深焙的豆子去冲
也是OK
你要冲给我吧
你没有喝到
你没喝到
我自己在家试的
我感到害怕
下次来试来看
我觉得还好
哦
所以不只可以修飾酸也可以修飾苦
因為它其實後段沒有萃取很多
好我們來講一下這個萃取的原理好了
我們都知道嘛就是
萃取就大致上分為香氣
前段很多香氣
然後和酸質
然後中間是比較多的甜感
最後是苦味
所以通常大部分的萃取呢
都要盡量避免到後面的苦味的萃取
要嘛就是有一些人提前結束萃取
就是我不要萃到那麼多
然後後面用加水的方式去吸食它
另外一種做法就是降溫去讓後段萃取比較那麼高曝谷哲他分享這個做法用了兩個第一個就是降溫然後第二個是浸泡所以他等於是說
他讓前段的味道盡可能去萃取出來
用高溫然後去用低率盡可能萃取出來之後
後段我們就降溫
然後並且用浸泡了
就比較不會出現那些苦澀感
我覺得是很合理
而且很天才的一個想法
我覺得布魯澤一直都是一個很學歷派嗎
就是他朋友為什麼
他可以把理論和實作放在一起
對對對
有些人是我是一個感覺
我吃了就是很好喝
你就是相信我
然後他會告訴你說
為什麼這樣好喝
然後覺得好厲害
其實很有道理
前面用低律盡可能萃取風味
然後後面用低溫浸泡
然後讓味道不要那麼過頭
但是又不滿足口感
我覺得很值得推薦給大家
對對對
其實就是跟之前我們講過很多低濾加進的方式
它也是什麼濾杯都可以用
還可以再補充一下就是
跟四六法的邏輯有點像
復古則有說如果前面兩段
你如果想要讓甜感多一點點的話
那你就第二段注水量增加
然後第一段減少
那如果你想要讓酸質多一點點的話
那就第一段增加第二段減少
那個大家可以回顧一下我們吃的吧影片
對我們之前有解釋過為什麼這個做法
會讓酸和甜的比例味道不一樣
所以大家也可以去做一些微調
不一定說都60-60
可以50-70
或是70-50
甚至80-40之類的
那今天跟大家分享這個呢
是普遍來自上帝的食譜
那大家可以在家裡自己試看看
好那今天影片就到這邊結束了
如果喜歡我們的影片的話呢
也請分享給有在喝咖啡的朋友們
如果想要看我們分享其他不同的手法
也歡迎在底下留言
那我們下次見囉
掰掰